the massive winter storm is also slowing
down efforts to distribute the
coronavirus vaccine
with some areas shutting down
vaccination sites last week
one hospital in seattle faced a
different type of challenge
forcing a mad dash to use 600 doses
before they went bad jonathan vigliotti
shows us the staff's quick reaction
after a refrigerator broke
more than one thousand people some even
in pajamas
lined up to get an unexpected shot of
the coronavirus vaccine
[Applause]
after a refrigerator holding 1600 doses
malfunctioned thursday night threatening
to spoil the whole batch
i called a few nursing leaders 30
minutes later we're all on site and just
gearing up for a mass vaccination effort
it was a frantic scramble to get as many
vaccinated as possible
including those who are not high
priority it's a mad dash reality playing
out across the country
doctors trying to vaccinate people with
excess doses
before they expire in oregon last week
health care workers transporting
vaccines
got stuck in a snow storm they knocked
on car windows and delivered doses to as
many stranded drivers
as they could we want to do everything
we can not to waste
any doses washington state health
department's dr umer shah
says it's critical for statewide systems
to work
in emergencies these systems are are
really working around the clock to make
sure that they coordinate
and at the end of the day if you have an
urgent situation in the middle of the
night
that we have a way to actually transfer
or be able to handle that situation
he says infrastructure is vital but
according to a recent report from
propublica
the federal system for tracking any
vaccines spoiled or thrown out
nationwide
has fallen short with reporting rules
not reliably communicated to vaccine
providers
or regularly enforced and wastage
numbers not reported to the public
luckily dr shaw says last week's hustle
showed good communication at the state
level
can save doses when accidents do happen
we coordinated throughout that system of
local
health care to the local jurisdiction
and obviously to the state
health department and none of those
doses were wasted
good nothing was wasted that was
jonathan bigliotti reporting